hey guys I'm Abby char welcome to Abby's
kitchen you asked and I am answering
we're gonna do another review of a what
I eat in a day video so I've done a few
videos where I've reviewed freelee the
banana girls what I in a day videos and
a lot of you have chimed in with some
suggestions on other youtubers to review
so I saw a lot of requests for fully raw
Kristina's videos so I'm gonna do a
review of one of her most recent what I
eat in a day so let's do this so in a
lot of Christina's videos she talks
about how she's not about pushing any
particular diet on people but you're she
is peddling her diet app which kudos for
being entrepreneurial that's awesome but
I mean this app does cost money so it's
not totally accessible for people a and
B they're talking a lot about the
importance of on juice cleanses for nice
gradients skin and the importance of
eating only organic raw foods which
newsflash is kind of sounding like a
diet to me
Oh Cristina hue the I rule right here so
I'm seeing of course one of my favorite
nutrition buzzwords detox specifically
if she's talking about heavy metal
detoxing switch that's hardcore but if
you have not already watched my full
video on detoxes and cleanses I highly
highly highly recommend you check it out
right here but bottom line guys our
bodies are amazing they have all the
resources that they need to detox and
cleanse every single day we don't need
green juice
to do it
[Music]
oh my god what is up with these portion
sizes with these ladies my goodness it
makes me kind of anxious and not just
watching them drink so much liquid so I
am all about the fat cheese I'm so
excited to see her make like an all
veggie juice that's really great but
like she's missing out on the fiber the
fiber is where lots of the benefits
happen that's what's good for gut health
that's what's gonna keep you satiated
longer you would feel so satisfied
having eaten like a fraction of the
vegetables that she just threw into that
juice because of all that fiber really
does fill you up I think about how
expensive that juice probably is you
could definitely get away with consuming
far less food and therefore saving a lot
of money while still getting all the
benefits that you're after had you just
eaten the food in its natural whole
state I can't imagine bringing all of
that in Tupperware to work with me and
like busting out like a party platter
for one I don't own enough Tupperware in
order to pack all that up each day not
to mention I don't think I would get
anything done in a day if I have to eat
all of that I mean think about the jaw
work involved if that's quite the
workout and a lot of prep work as well
that could probably take you like a few
hours just prepare your casual lunch for
one for one day know
[Music]
okay so I'm really excited watching this
salad be put together it is absolutely
gorgeous the colors the textures this
looks like something I would be really
excited to dig into however I'm a little
concerned that there's not a whole lot
of stay shading components like protein
that would really help balance this out
to help people eat intuitively I mean
when you're just eating vegetables it's
very easy to just feel like you're never
really satiated because you're not
getting you know a lot of that protein
that's going to help fill you up to help
satisfy you so I just want to make sure
that people who are watching this at
home don't think that they only have to
eat vegetables and that's gonna be
what's gonna have to fill them up the
reality is there's a lot of other food
components that will really do a great
job at making you feel your best
so that dressing looks absolutely
amazing I'm totally wanting to try that
myself however that's a very large
portion of salad dressing and it really
is just indicative of what a large salad
that really is and have we seen some you
know good quality slow-burning
carbohydrates in there and some protein
we wouldn't feel the need to just be
loading up on a massive expensive bowl
of vegetables and a very large container
of salad dressing yes I love that
there's good fats not tahini and the
oils however I would love to see some
more protein and some good slow burning
carbs in there to help balance it out
okay so let's talk about a few things
first of all is Kristina's day
nutritionally adequate so based on our
calculations Kristina is getting about
2,500 calories and her macronutrient
distribution is 17% from protein 27%
from fat and 47% from carbohydrates so
Kristina's diet actually looks pretty
good from a macronutrient distribution
however from a micronutrient
distribution she's getting about 52
servings of fruits and vegetables a day
where the recommendation is between 8 to
10 now I can tell you because I see this
every single day most North American
adults really struggle to even get the
eight to ten servings a day so what I'm
seeing Kristina pull off here is really
unachievable for most people and not
necessarily what I would recommend
anyway even though we know that fruits
and vegetables are super healthy for us
when it's at this level of extreme more
is not necessarily better especially
when it's displacing other really
important nutrients and minerals so as a
dietician this is why we look at people
as an individual because a diet like
Christina's while it may work for her is
really inappropriate for a lot of other
people so now let's talk about what
Christina is not really getting in her
diet
so since she's not consuming any animal
products it's likely that Christina is a
little bit low in things like vitamin D
and b12 so definitely hoping that she's
taking a supplement and well I don't
really see any greens here she's
definitely getting a lot of fiber from
that massive big salad she's consuming
and the veggie platter with the hummus
which is great however she's getting
about 93 grams of fiber in her day when
the recommendation is 25 grams again I
am so all for fiber I'm always telling
people about the merits of getting more
fiber because most North Americans are
just not even getting to that minimum
however when you're looking at the
extreme amounts that Christina is it's
very likely that you're suffering from
things like bloating cramping and
regularity disturbances so let's talk
about the cost associated with
Christina's diet so Christina actually
has a video where she talks about how
you can eat vegan for $20 a day which
maybe sounds kind of good but actually
is a lot that amounts to about $600 a
month
for one single person whereas the u.s.
liberal cost plan suggests that the
average female adult spends 327 dollars
a month on food so Christina is actually
spending twice as much as the average
and that's just not accessible for
clearly most North Americans okay
Christina so here's the deal I am 100%
all for a plant-based diet
however I really think that the diet
that you're promoting based on what I
see here is expensive its time consuming
and is just not balanced I mean there is
a lot of ways to do plant-based well and
this is just really not it also I think
issue somebody who suggests that they
are in camp diet culture yet this clean
eating detox and cleanse rhetoric
definitely appears to people's
relationship with food honestly the
whole wellness industry is just the diet
in the street with a new coat of
lipstick it is still not intuitive it is
still restrictive and it is still just
another set of rules honestly Kristina's
diet has all the makings of a pretty
strenuous serious diet and I'm gonna
take a hard pass so guys I hope you
enjoyed this video if you did be sure to
give us a thumbs up leave me a comment
below some ideas for some what I eat in
a day videos that you want me to review
subscribe to the channel and I'll see
you next time on Abby's kitchen bye
[Music]